[Music]
this morning we're learning about new
efforts to protect manatees some of the
most beloved marine mammals in florida
unfortunately they have been dying in
record numbers this year ben tracy went
to florida to find out what's
threatening the manatees and what's
being done to save them
the manatees they really are everywhere
they're all around us the amenities are
literally everywhere this morning it's a
flotilla of florida manatees just
hanging out in the morning mist there's
like six or seven right right here
they're literally like stacked on top of
each other here it's a manatee traffic
jam it is a vanity traffic jam
cora burcham works for the non-profit
save the manatee nearly every morning
here at florida's blue springs state
park she hand counts the manatees that
flock here in the winter for the warm
water we've had days in here where we've
had over 600 manatees wow oh that's
hairy
that was harry
harry the manatee she knows most by name
because of their distinctive scars from
being hit by boat propellers they're
like family you know they're like family
coming back
burcham is now worried that many of them
may not survive
manatees have been starving to death
their bones even washing up on shore
while zoos in places such as sea world
rushed to rescue the emaciated marine
mammals having lost hundreds of manatees
to starvation that's never happened
before
patrick rose is executive director of
save the manatee and says starvation is
the leading cause of a drastic spike in
manatee deaths more than one thousand of
them have died so far this year that's
more than any year in state history it's
especially grim considering there are
just about 6 000 manatees in all of
florida's waters many of those manatees
that did finally succumb to the
starvation their organs were really
deteriorated it was just really an
agonizing death more than half of the
manatees have died here inside the
indian river lagoon which stretches for
more than 150 miles along florida's east
coast and the reason they're starving is
because their food is disappearing
manatees are vegetarians and often
called sea cows because they eat a lot
of sea grass more than 100 pounds a day
but for about a decade now the sea grass
has been disappearing that's because of
human-caused water pollution from
florida's development boom mainly sewage
from septic systems and fertilizer
runoff from nearby farms that helped
fuel a recent series of algae super
blooms in florida they darken the water
and block out the sun killing the sea
grass the manatees are left struggling
to find food we think we're right at the
tipping point dennis hannisack is a
researcher at the harbor branch
oceanographic institute where they're
experimenting with growing seagrass in
these large tanks and then transplanting
it into the lagoon to try to restore
some of the lost sea grass beds how much
sea grass has been lost 60 to 80 percent
if you look maybe at the whole lagoon by
some estimates repairing the massive
lagoon will require 5 billion dollars
and much tougher pollution rules so for
now desperate animal welfare
organizations have even resorted to hand
feeding manatees romaine lettuce
good job guys more than 130 manatees
have been rescued this year and slowly
nursed back to health this manatee
anastasia had lost much of her body
weight but in october she was strong
enough to be released
burcham says it's humans that caused
this problem and we need to fix it it's
not going to be a quick fix i strongly
believe if we all work together and we
all do our part we can still make a
difference
for cbs morning's ben tracy vero beach
florida
i love this story i love what ben's able
to do with these stories that he tells
he sets it up so beautifully you see
these beautiful pictures of manatees you
see the handlers who know them by name
yes and then he explains by the way
we're killing them because of pollution
in the water but then goes on to say we
still can do something about it save
them we're saying it's awesome yeah
humans cause this problem and now humans
fix it they can fix it right space was
produced by superb energy this is really
great i really enjoyed it really great